something that we haven't heard about as
much as I thought we would through week
one of the preseason the replay review
procedures for pass interference only 14
red flags thrown in the 16 games played
between Thursday and Saturday night
Chris we need to have these flags thrown
more often we need to have more reps for
this system I know it slows down the
preseason games but we all need to get
an idea of what it's going to be like
the coaches need to know the fans need
to know the media needs to know our
River on needs the reps the the replay
officials in the stadium and the referee
going over talking to our River arm
while all of that stuff it needs to be
worked on now so they can spot any
problems fix them or if nothing else
just be ready to go when that first game
of the season rolls around in only three
weeks and three days I'm surprised it
was what 16 is that what we said it was
the amount of challenges from this past
week I mean I am surprised with that
number I thought it would probably be
more than that I'm not gonna lie I hear
what you're saying I mean I don't want
it I don't want to see it because I
don't want it to slow down and bog the
games down even in the preseason hey the
preseason games they're not the most
exciting things to watch on all the
television history anyways so to have
that aspect of it can be a little bit
annoying but I understand your point and
the more that the these plays are
challenged the more we can flush out
these unintended consequences like the
play we talked about during the show
today which was of course that Kansas
City Chiefs Cincinnati Bengals Oh
challenge to see if it was offensive
pass interference looked like it was to
me wasn't called they left it on the
field as an incomplete pass and you
brought up all the right questions to
you know what's the result of the play
is that affecting the review and what's
ultimately being decided within the
review there I worry about that because
that did look like OPI and I just I
would love to continue to hear the
dialogue and and I hope at some point
during this week we hear a liver on
explain that play thoroughly to us so we
can get a better feel of how they are
officiating it and what he saw so we're
not kind of in the dark about some of
these situations yeah and there needs to
be transparency but there also needs to
be a recognition about hue
nature will factor into this and I am
firmly convinced that non call of
offensive pass interference was driven
by the fact that the ball wasn't caught
by the receiver and as you pointed out
it could have been intercepted but for
the past interference if the if the
penalty happens it needs to be called
and I will say this the one time that
that I think it worked exactly the way
it should by way of reversing ruling on
the field it came earlier in that same
game chief spangles earlier in that same
2-minute window where the replay
official has the authority to activate
replay review byron Pringle was hit
early blown up before the ball got there
and it was obvious the defensive back
Dovan to him the ball came in flag
thrown pass interference that's what the
rule is there to fix not well maybe he
grabbed his wrist maybe he still could
have caught it the situation where the
guy gets wiped out and the ball shows up
later that is the perfect opportunity to
overturn an on call of pass interference
and I applaud that one I still don't
like the one from Thursday night Chris
with the Jets and the Giants I still
think it's not the high bar that it
needs to be at the moment you see it
full speed ok it's interference if you
should have to watch it two or three or
four times it's not clear enough to
overturn but the one from Center on that
field you can't be mad at that just
because you don't get it from your TV
angle there was obviously 90 people on
the sidelines including a coach who saw
it and they wanted a throne so you know
once you saw the replay and you saw a
clear view four times once I saw it four
times okay I still don't know that I
still don't know that grabbing his wrist
kept him from catching the ball you're
still saying that's absolutely insane
you're just being stubborn Mike Florio
and your first take was you weren't sure
and you won't back off of it and you
know that was past interference and you
can't you can't argue all the things you
just argued about the Chiefs bangles
game and then say you're not sure about
that one when a guy held on to it for
more than one count more than two count
and he couldn't get his hand up there so
don't you know that was P I maybe I'm
starting to understand why Antonio Brown
refuses to change helmets
[Laughter]
yeah I just still think that it needs to
be before you're gonna involve replay
review for a subjective call it needs to
be very clear and there need to be some
that we may say you know what it looked
like interference but it's got to be an
obvious interference like byron Pringle
pushing the guy's head like Byron
Pringle getting blown up by the Bengals
defensive back so well again throw the
red flag more here's my point yeah
coaches throw the red flag on every pass
interference call or non call one of the
two coaches whoever got screwed throw
the red flag let's work this out let's
have more examples that we can discuss
we can flesh it out and understand how
this is going to work going for
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports